hello everybody and welcome to another
matplotlib tutorial on our little
matplotlib mini series for python 3
where we left off we were covering
legends and grids and then still kind of
a continuation of our Styles now what I
want to do is go ahead and begin to
cover different charting so right now so
far we've only covered like line charts
but there's actually quite a few other
things that we can do with map plot live
we can plot even so much as on a map but
we can do pie charts and we can do
scatter plots and bar charts all this
stuff so I'd like to show you guys
scattered scatter plots and bar charts
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so we have x and y we'll keep
those on I don't want to change the grid
anymore
let's go actually I'll show you first
with that style and then we'll add in
style we'll leave all the title and we
can leave the legend actually let's get
rid of legend we don't need this ok so
instead of PLT deploy we can use PLT dot
scatter for one so we can do scatter and
then come down here and do scatter and
we're going to get rid of line width we
don't really care about that anymore
here label will keep and the colors of
scatter will keep in fact actually let's
get we're done doing the colors now so
I'll just show you colors with styles
okay so scatter so let's go ahead and
save and run that and here we get our
scatter plot and in fact to kind of go
back and show you guys the colors so
anyway because it kind of matters with
scatter plots and it actually matters
with bar charts too so these are two
different data sets so usually people
want to like color their data sets very
specifically so let's try on Styles real
quick though and we can see the even
Styles didn't give us the color so close
out of this and actually so what we're
going to do here is we don't need a
label anymore either so we're not doing
legend but we can might not be able to
get away with this we'll see if we get
away with cyan and green let's say let's
see if that works when I have to specify
color yeah yeah so what we want to do
here is actually probably color equal
see color equals G there we go so now
you can see we've chosen probably pretty
poor colors for any sort of actual
visualization but just so you can see
one data set is colored cyan the other
data set is green so we can actually see
you know there's a different data set
here so that's colors and scatters so as
you can see probably you know the
whatever the third value is to scatter
its not color because it didn't work out
for us
um so really I think that's all I wanted
to show you with scatter plots just
basically that they exist and that's how
you can call them now the next thing I
want to show you guys is bar charts so
we can actually change from scatter to
bar and just do bar and really
everything can stay the same here I
believe so we should be able to get away
with just bar yeah
okay so we've kind of well we've ran
into a couple of issues here first
issues that there's some overlap going
on so we did not make a stacked bar
chart instead we're overlapping our bars
so let's go cuz we're using the same x
and y so 5 6 7 8 let's change these to
like 2 or 6a and then 1 3 5 7
ok so they're not like right on top of
each other now there we go much better
so we've got bar charts again they're
different colors because if you didn't
specify different colors that would be
the exact same color it's very silly I
don't know why they do the lines
different colors naturally by default
but not bars and scatters it doesn't
make any sense but they don't so anyway
so those are different colors but I do
want to point out again let's bring this
chart up um reading this chart let's say
you're reading it I don't know at least
for me when I look at a bar chart I want
the bars to be
centered over the value that they
represents because my question here is
this is representing five where is it
representing six is it representing like
five point three what are we
representing here so close out of this
and actually let me bring it one more
time and I'm a little curious actual
let's get rid of styles usually I
thought they went all the way to the
next value but no they clearly don't
interesting anyway so this is the
original with the outline and everything
beautiful so you can kind of see that
it's airing more on the side of the the
left number right so there's a little
bit of gap before we get to the next one
but it's still I'm not a fan of it so a
lot of people are going to ask how do we
fix that as far as like getting it
centered over the value it represents
it's actually quite simple we just use
align equals Center and then we do the
same thing down here otherwise we're
going to get really confused really fast
along Center same to run that and now we
can see that we've actually aligned our
bars over the value that they represent
to me that just makes the chart way
easier to read so so yeah anyway that's
going to conclude this tutorial on
plotting bar charts and scatter plots in
the next video probably going to be the
last video I cover here on matplotlib
basics we're just going to be reading
from a CSV file and plotting from that
CSV file you can use this to plot from
text files to it doesn't have to be a
CSV necessarily so anyway that's what
we're going to be doing in the next
video again if there's more
customization or more things that you'd
like to learn how to plot matplotlib
also allows you to plot in three
dimensions so you can do 3d scatter
plots 3d bar charts 3d plane plots and
all of this I do have tutorials on all
of that you just have just search in my
channel for what you're looking for I've
got a pretty extensive series on that
plot lid but I just wanted to cover the
basics in this playlist too so anyway
that's going to clue this video if you
guys have any questions or comments for
freely then below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and it's a
next time